[Musique]
la planète shadow qui a été rétréci par
la maladie les shadoks font route vers
la terre entassés dans leurs ustensiles
venait d'abord le chef shadoks dans sa
casserole personnel plus de 20 plombier
dans son lavabo et le professeur shadow
coup le reste de la population suivait
et comme elle pouvait il y avait des
shadoks en boîte des châteaux quand
casserole ou à la poêle et même des
shadoks en tube évidemment il était un
peu à l'étroit mais il avait quand même
du choix car quand un château qu'on
avait assez de vivre dans un tiroir du
haut par exemple ils pouvaient
s'installer dans un tiroir du bas et
même vice et versa mais tout était plein
de shadocks et pour la cuisine c'était
pape raconte quand on voulait faire
cuire des nouilles par exemple il
fallait déménager les shadoks qui
habitait dans le fourneau en attendons
les installer dans l'aude et nous quand
c'était cuit et des ménages et des
shadoks qui habitait dans la passoire et
on les mettait dans le fourneau ont
passé une première fois pour récupérer
l'eau dans le tourneau on passait une
deuxième fois pour récupérer les
nouilles apa enfin on passait le
fourneau pour récupérer l'eau à ce
moment là les nous tomber et on pouvait
recommencer quand il y avait vraiment
trop de shadocks dans les ustensiles au
nom jeu d'être cool mais depuis qu'il
avait plu
blaney le groupe n'était qu'un trou avec
rien autour et les chats de contrôle se
mettait à tomber ou à tourner autour des
planètes continent passait on les
appelait des satellites et c'est depuis
ce ton là d'ailleurs qui l'y attend de
satellites dans l'espace
[Musique]